unsere Reise durch die Schweiz soll auf
2.33 Metern beginnen zusammen mit Martin
nelle von der moosfluh aus einem
Aussichtspunkt im Wallis wollen wir auf
den Aletschgletscher wandern mit seinen
ca 22 Kilometern ist der der längste
Eisstrom der Alpen
deine Beziehung zum Gletscher ja ich bin
so oft auf diesem
auch meinen Freund
über Zwiesprache mit ihm eigentlich wenn
der dann wieder zurückgeschmolzen ist
ich weiter hinunterlaufen muss wieder
weiter zurück nach oben natürlich dann
sagen wir dann du bist ein fauler Hund
dass du die nur gut für deine Kondition
ich werde auch nicht jünger
schon lange muss Martin zusehen wie der
Alex schrumpft
wie viele der mehr als 200.000 Gletscher
weltweit
[Musik]
ging der Gletscher mal passiert und noch
weiter
also der letzte Höchststand war 18 59 60
in diesem 160 Jahren ist
zurückgeschmolzen die Masse ist
natürlich noch viele Männer viel
schlimmer eigentlich so viele und im
Moment die letzten Jahre da geht es
eigentlich sehr schnell
Martin beobachtet das fast täglich wo
will er uns zeigen
die Gletscher sind wichtige
süßwasserspeicher denn auch wenn die
Oberfläche unserer Erde zu etwa zwei
Dritteln mit Wasser bedeckt ist der
Großteil des Wassers auf unserer Erde
ist Salzwasser der Anteil an Süßwasser
viel kleiner
das meiste davon ist wiederum im Eis der
Gletscher und der Pole gespeichert als
Trinkwasser zugänglich ist nur ein
kleiner Teil des Süßwassers
[Musik]
im Sommer gegen Gletscher immer Wasser
ab vor allem in Dürreperioden
Klimawandel hat sich etwas verändert im
Winter kommt wenig neues Eis nach im
Sommer schmilzt mehr die Wasserspeicher
drohen leer zu laufen in der Schweiz und
weltweit welche Folgen kann das haben in
Zürich treffen wir den Glaziologen
Matthias Hus
die Berge wir haben riesige Gletscher in
Alaska in Patagonien Südamerika am
dritten Pool in Asien also im Himalaya
und CaraCum und diese Gletscher sind
besonders wichtig
diese deutsche haben einerseits das
Potenzial wirklich massiv zum
Meeresspiegelanstieg beizutragen und
andererseits gerade wenn wir nach Asien
schauen sind dort die Gletscher
besonders wichtig für die Wasser
Verfügbarkeit diese großen Gletscher
sagt er seien noch zu retten aber wie
eigentlich gibt es nur eines was wir tun
können wir müssen das Klima schützen
[Musik]
dafür kämpft eine Frau mit der wir in
Zürich verabredet sind weil sie wie
viele ihrer Generation die Folgen der
Hitze spürt sie ist vor den Europäischen
Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte gezogen
hallo schön dass wir hier sein dürfen
oder Müller 78 gehört zu den Klima
Seniorinnen die Gruppe klagt gegen die
Schweizer Regierung ihr Ziel ist es sie
dazu zu bringen effektiveren Klimaschutz
einzuführen wenn ich meine üblichen
Ausgänge nicht mehr machen kann und in
der Wohnung bleibe weil es so heiß ist
dann ist es so meine Isolation
ich weiß dass es die Untersuchung gibt
dass vor allem Frauen über 75
stärker unter der Hitze leiden der
Kreislauf ist viel anfälliger
und sie werden schneller krank und
sterben sogar schneller
und das war ist ja auch unser Anliegen
weil der Klage vor Schweizer Gerichten
waren die Klima Seniorinnen gescheitert
nun setzen Sie auf das Gericht in
Straßburg
[Musik]
wenn Sie diesen Punkt
anerkennen würden das wäre ganz viel
geworden das ist meine Hoffnung wir
fahren mit oder in Ihren Garten mit Bus
und Tram ihr Auto hat sie verkauft sie
fliegt nicht mehr widmet ihr Leben dem
klimaaktivismus
einfach dass ich manchmal weinen muss
wenn ich danach wenn ich wieder eine
Meldung lese die einfach so
unverständlich ist
und dann pack ich rede an also ich kann
ja dann nicht in dem verharren ich
musste dann nicht was tun ich denke
danach an meine Enkel was für eine Welt
finden Sie vor wenn Sie 30 sind 40
können Sie dann noch Kinder haben so
dann deine Generation oder ältere
Generation haben da Fehler gemacht wir
haben einfach gelebt und alles
konsumiert was es gab ja alles und klar
der Bericht vom Körper froh hab das
gelesen oh schlimm und so aber geändert
habe ich an meinem Verhalten nichts ich
bin weiter geflogen habe Auto gefahren
macht
etwas gemacht wie mächtig fühlst du dich
da was verändern zu können
ich weigere mich mich auf das
Ohnmachtsgefühl einzulassen ich mache
einfach und ich denke einfach durch
meinen Vorbild oder durch meinen Handeln
vielleicht stecke ich jemand an
wir möchten oder noch zu einer Aktion
begleiten und verabreden uns für den
nächsten Tag
erst einmal fahren wir nach
fischbach-göslikon eine kleine Gemeinde
in der Nähe von Zürich hier leben 1.715
Menschen gut situiert in der
vorstadt-idylle aber es gibt ein Problem
das Grundwasser wird knapp
wo sind wir hier
auf 30 Meter Tiefe wollen
seit Jahren aber notiert der
Brunnenmeister ein immer niedrigeren
Pegelstand
wo steht die Nadel denn sonst ich sag
jetzt mal vor fünf Jahren etwa drei
Meter höher
das Grundwasser droht auszugehen schon
das zweite Jahr in Folge die
Gemeinderäte einer von ihnen ist Andreas
wiss zogen Konsequenzen Auto waschen
Pool füllen oder Rasen gießen das ist
hier seit April verboten alles was über
den täglichen Bedarf innerhalb des
Haushaltes hinausgeht ist eigentlich im
Grunde untersagt für wie lange ist
erstmal unklar denn selbst wenn es jetzt
regnet oder gewittert nichts davon gehe
ins Grundwasser also es muss im Winter
regnen oder viel Schnee geben damit
dieses Wasser versickern kann das ist
die Zeit in der die Vegetation am
wenigstens Wasser benötigt und auch die
privaten Haushalten wenigsten Wasser
benötigen auch speziell auch für die
Gärten und so weiter was sagen die Leute
im Ort dazu
in diesem Pool erzählt mir Mike sei noch
Wasser vom vergangenen Jahr andere im
Ort hätten sich extra Wasser liefern
lassen
es ist ein Luxus aber für dich
mehr wenn man auf einmal so drauf
schauen muss was ist dir keine Sorgen
ich glaube so weit sind wir noch nicht
das wird uns da groß Sorgen machen
müssen manche im Ort kritisieren das
Wasser sparen überhaupt notwendig
geworden ist
ich sage Politik hätte ich sage die
Politik hat es verschlafen sie haben den
Problem zu wenig Beachtung geschenkt man
kannte doch den Grundwasserspiegel und
jetzt ist zu wenig da und der Bürger
muss dafür gerade stehen
tatsächlich ist das Problem seit Jahren
bekannt auch dem
gemeinderatsvorsitzenden
Trinkwasser ist zu einem wertvollen Gut
geworden selbst in unseren breitengraben
und das ist ein Erkenntnis das muss in
den Köpfen zuerst wachsen
nun sich mit mehr als 20 anderen
Gemeinden zu vernetzen um die
Wasserversorgung sicherzustellen in
zukünftigen Sommern soll für alles genug
Wasser da sein
zurück auf dem Aletschgletscher mit
Bergführer Martin hier war das Eis
am 4.7
ist diese Menge über zwei Meter
abgeschmolzen
aber in Hitze soll man fließt sehr viel
Wasser ab
2003 hatten wir Spitzen Abflussmengen
von 120.000 Litern in der Sekunde und
letztes Jahr obwohl die Fläche kleiner
viel kleiner geworden ist in 20 Jahren
aber letztes Jahr waren es mal
128.000 Liter in der Sekunde
es beschleunigt eindeutig weniger Fläche
vielleicht
wenn Gletscher wie der Alex kleiner
werden wird irgendwann kein Wasser mehr
fließen es wird fehlen zur
Stromerzeugung der Landwirtschaft als
Trinkwasser es drohen extreme Dürre
Perioden
Folge des Klimawandels
ist schon sehr traurig für mich
eigentlich so das ganze Bild mein ganzes
Leben das fließt eigentlich an mir
vorbei also eine gletscherschmilz vor
den Augen Weg der schwitzen nur noch
Martins Freund der Alex zieht sich
zurück immer höher in die Berge
wie viel verloren gehen könnte zeigen
Animationen der ETH Zürich
selbst wenn es die Weltgemeinschaft
schafft die globale Erwärmung unter zwei
Grad zu halten während bis Ende des
Jahrhunderts nur noch 40% des
eisvolumens von 2019 übrig
bei einer Erderwärmung von mehr als 4
Grad könnten vom Aletsch bis Ende des
Jahrhunderts nur noch ein paar Eisfelder
übrig sein
eine Schweiz ohne Gletscher die wird
weiter existieren das ist nicht der
Weltuntergang aber wenn wir über
dürren extremen Niederschläge
Meeresspiegelanstieg sprechen Auftauen
des Permafrostes in den arktischen
Regionen das sind unglaubliche
Konsequenzen die die Welt als Ganzes
Schwert zu beleben machen wird in Zürich
treffen wir noch einmal die
klimaaktivistin oder Müller ich habe mir
gestern schon darüber gesprochen dass
mich die Zukunft eigentlich ängstigt und
ich bin gespannt ob diese Workshop etwas
daran ändern kann das Thema ihrer Gruppe
ist Dürre sie stellen sich vor wie die
Welt in 20 Jahren sein könnte mit dabei
ist Rita auch bei den Klima Seniorinnen
den startup-gründer noe und die
Designerin Juliana kannten sie vorher
nicht hier treffen zwei Generationen
aufeinander
wie geht's euch damit in die Zukunft zu
blicken ich finde spannend also für euch
ist dass die Zukunft
es ist für dich nicht die Zukunft ja
also ob ich das noch bewusst weiß so
mitbekommen das weiß ich nicht das frage
ich mich manchmal ich vertrete die
Meinung dass mit Angst nicht so viel zu
erreichen ist und ich eher da das
wichtig finde mit Optimismus
radikalen Optimismus zu sagen okay wird
schon gemeinsam entwerfen Sie eine
Vision ein Wasser Verteilsystem in Dürre
Zeiten
Klima folgen
kann ist eine Strategie Mann resilien
und Adaptierung
Fähigkeit
das ist toll dass ihr den Optimismus hat
mir manchmal
doch tatenlos zusehen will oder auch
nicht will weiter kämpfen für mehr
Klimaschutz und die Zukunft ihrer Enkel
außerdem in unserer
auslandsjournal-reihe Kampf ums Wasser
also wenn die für die Seite der Tiere
entscheiden haben wir in der Klinik kein
Wasser